[Música]
[Aplausos]
buenas tardes hoy vengo a contarles mi
historia de vida
en mí en mi infancia pasamos muchas
necesidades
escasez
a veces no teníamos ni para comer
para poder obtener dinero llegamos a
juntar la materia fecal de los caballos
para poder vender a las ladrillerías
mi papá hacía changas en la época de
cosecha de algodón nos mudábamos al
paraje llamado los lapachos a unos 40 km
así todo trabajábamos para poder ayudar
mis padres siempre fueron grandes
luchadores de cual hoy estoy muy
orgulloso
a la escuela solamente podíamos asistir
de agosto a diciembre que eran los meses
que volvíamos a vivir a nuestro pueblo
ahí estoy con mi guardapolvo de jardín
a mí me encantaba ir a la escuela
desde que asistí a jardín mi tía me
lleva y me trae a todos los días
tanto me gusta ver el jardín que un día
le dije a mi maestra que ese día mi papá
me iba a buscar pero no era así él no
sabía nada un rato después fue a
buscarme porque yo no regresaba a mi
casa
pobre de mi maestra que se tuvo que
quedar hasta ese momento para cuidarme
pero yo estaba feliz de estar con ella
cuando tenía 10 años aproximadamente
mis papás cansados andar de un lado para
otro como golondrinas decidieron venir a
vivir la reconquista
mi papá le dijo a mi mamá que tenía casa
y trabajo acá pero no era así
vivimos la casa unos tíos
donde pasamos momentos muy difíciles
porque no éramos libres de jugar de
estar tranquilo no era nuestra casa
además nos ponían horario para poder
utilizar la cocina
entonces mi mamá para no molestar hacía
fuego y cocinaba
un tiempo después
y consiguieron un terreno donde pudieron
hacer un rancho con techo de paja
paredes de barro ni bien la terminaron
nos mudamos ni siquiera se habían secado
las paredes hasta el punto que nos
despertábamos todos embarrados porque
dormido nos apoyábamos en ella mi papá
seguía siendo changa cartoneaba vendían
lo que encontraba en la calle
dos años después
él consiguió un trabajo estable y ahí
mejoró un poco nuestra situación
económica
en mi época de secundaria asistí por
varias instituciones escolares
curso hasta tercer año y abandoné
porque en ese momento no era responsable
no era constante además como nadie me
exigía nada decidí dejar
de chica siempre tuve un gran sueño
ser maestra jardinera ser docente
pero cómo lograría esa meta si ni
siquiera había terminado mis estudios
secundario
pero esa ese sueño
seguía latente en mi mente en mi corazón
enseñar para mí era una vocación pero no
hacía nada para lograr eso
trabajé como niñera empleada doméstica
ganaba muy poquito y trabajaba muchas
horas pero lo seguía haciendo
porque de algo tenía que mantenerme
cuando tenía 18 años aprendí a coser a
máquina esa esa pedal que utilizan
nuestras abuelas también enseñaba tejido
en el salón comunitario de mi barrio
hacía prendas para vender tejida ropa de
niños con telas que me donaban
mi primera oportunidad
apareció en el 2007
cuando una vecina me comenta que en un
taller textil estaba necesitando
personal para trabajar en máquinas
industriales
me presenté me entrevistaron y quedaron
en llamarme
en este momento sentí que ese era mi
lugar
espere a que me llamen
solo le pedía a dios que quería esta
oportunidad para poder progresar
dos semanas después me llamaron comencé
a trabajar
era mi primer trabajo formal
una inmensa alegría me invadía
pero lo que más me gustó es que ganaría
el triple de lo que ganaba trabajando
como niñera
y operar ya ocho meses
después fui supervisora de la línea de
trabajo donde también aprendí mecánica
en el 2011
llegó la gran oportunidad de mi vida
la gran oportunidad de cumplir mis
sueños el que tenía de cuando era
pequeña
me eligieron para ser capacitador de
confección a nivel industrial
ni se imaginan la emoción que invadía mi
alma
y me dije esta es la mía la gran
oportunidad que estaba esperando para
enseñar mis conocimientos a personas que
quisieran aprender un oficio
pero lo que más me motivaba
es que esas personas tuvieran la misma
oportunidad que tú eso
de poder crecer de capacitarme
por eso los invito
a ustedes
que pueden dar oportunidades
hágalo
sobre todo los jóvenes
del es tiempo de adquirir experiencia
tengan es paciencia
como me la dieron y me la tuvieron a mí
sin haber terminado mis estudios
secundarios
llevo realizando esta tarea
de hace siete años
donde para lograrlo
tuve que aprender
moldear mi carácter
tuve que dejar la timidez me costó mucho
poder hablar en público
eres trabajando en este lugar
aprendí a valorarme
a quererme
sobre todas las cosas
a cumplir un horario
pero algo muy importante
le gané a mi pobreza mental
yo no puedo siempre voy a estar igual
hoy les puedo decir
que cumplía el gran sueño de mi vida
soy docente
y esta no fui por el camino formal para
lograrlo
pero soy una profesional
soy una docente de oficio muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]